hello everybody welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you're
all doing fine
today's class will be for men and women
the same but if you are a woman i
recommend you to the class without
tangled shoes without high heels because
it will be again hard on balance yeah
you will also need a stick and we will
use methanol today because i wanted to
focus on slower movements than the tempo
that we usually use yeah
and in today's class i would like to
invite you to work with me
in the way that i work for myself yeah
because usually in these videos i show
you a selection of exercises i explain
to you how i work and then i demonstrate
them for a few repetitions
but usually when i work for myself
i concentrate on less exercises and i
repeat them more yeah
and i also introduce little changes in
each repetition so that the exercise
becomes a bit harder as i go yeah so i
focus on less things and i work on them
deeper and at this point
i am focusing a lot for myself in my
basics in posture balance axis yeah
so
that's the point of this video to invite
you to work with me
in a session that i would do for myself
yeah the reason why i'm working on the
basics now is that for me they are the
most important thing
if you don't have a good posture
you don't have balance if you don't have
balance you can't do anything you cannot
embrace properly you cannot
stand on one leg you cannot use your
free leg the way you want you cannot do
steps so for me posture and balance are
the foundation of the building yeah
and
that's what we will do today in the way
that i would practice them myself yeah
so after the warm up we will have two
sections on the first section we will
work on posture
and we will
do three exercises and we will repeat
them quite a lot yeah
and then on the second block we will do
balance and again three exercises and we
will repeat them
a lot and we will introduce little
changes on each repetition as we go up
to make them a little bit more
challenging okay
so get ready i hope you enjoy the class
and let's go let's work together let's
start with the warm-up okay let's start
with the warm-up so feet together
breathe deeply then let the weight of
your body come down yeah feel the
pressure of your feet flat on the floor
and we start with shoulder rotations
yeah remember make them slow and big and
relax the elbows so that the elbows
don't come up when you are doing the
circle okay leave them
relaxed and down okay and we do it eight
times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight then we do arm circles
remember to keep the arms straight all
the time yeah don't bend the elbows
and then pass the hands behind your back
a little bit behind your back so that
you stretch the chest okay and we do it
big and slow we do it eight times okay
let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay now we stretch the side of our
torso so we raise one arm we slide down
our leg with the other hand until you
can touch the side of your knee then you
hold this stretch for three seconds then
you go back up and then you lower the
arm and we repeat with the other side
okay we do it four times to each side so
let's go
arm up one
go down
hold it
and go up lower down to the other side
one go down the leg
hold it
and
up
two
go down the leg
hold it
and up
and down arm up go down your leg
hold the stretch
and up
three arm up
put on the leg
hold the stretch
and up
three
pull down your leg
hold it
and up
four
go down the leg hold it
and up
and four
go down the leg hold the stretch
and up
okay now
we open our legs bend the knees lightly
and then keep the head the hips straight
looking forward and also the head
straight and looking forward make a
circle with your arms hands below the
chest and then rotate the torso left and
right from the waist not from the hip
yeah from the waist the belt is always
looking forward okay keep your head
looking forward also while you rotate
the torso and make sure that the arms
move together with the torso yeah
because if you move the arms
independently from the torso then you
are not working with the back which is
what you want okay
so
let's do it 16 times eight twice okay
let's go
one
two
four
five
six and seven and eight okay
now stretch the knees
legs straight
and then either put your hands behind
your back
your head the back of your head
or on your hips yeah
if you put your hands on the hips
remember the exercise is easier if you
put your hands behind the head the
exercise a little bit harder
um like you want yeah i will keep the
head my hands behind the head
and then we lower our back from the hip
until the back is parallel with the
floor and then we keep going down
bending the back and using
the weight of the head yeah then we
bounce three times one
two
three
and then we go back up slowly this is
one repetition and we do eight okay
so let's do it together
eight times one
go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
two
go down
balance bounce bounce
and go up
three
go down bounce bounce pass
and go up
four go down slowly relax on your
balance pass pass palms very relaxed
and go up
five
go down
bounce pass palms
and go up
six go down
pass bounce bounce
and walk
two left
seven
go down
palms pass palms go up and the last one
eight
go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up okay
now keep the legs open and put your
hands on your hips
then go back with your hip a little bit
then move your hip to the side yeah
notice that i keep my head on the same
place
i don't move the head okay i only move
the hip
huh and then i move my hip forward
and then to the other side
and then back yeah the head is always on
the same place
only the hip moves not the hand okay
and uh we do it eight times to one side
and then we change direction
and we do that hands to the other side
yeah try to make the circle as big as
you can yeah okay let's go eight times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
now to the other direction
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay
good now close your legs
and then the next exercise
is to strengthen your legs especially
your ankle muscles yeah so make sure
that your feet are together
touching each other and exactly parallel
okay contact
between the whole inside of both feet
okay of course legs together yeah knees
together everything
and pay attention to your core yeah make
sure that the hip is straight and your
core is engaged and then you can keep
your hands on your hips if you want or
you can put them behind your head yeah i
will keep them behind my head and then
we go down
we bend the knees and we go down and we
bounce three times one two three and
then we stretch the knees we go a little
bit forward and then we go up on our
toes yeah
trying that our legs don't open keep
them close and then down
slowly okay so let's do it three times
one
balance bounce bounce
and then go on the toes
and hold it a few seconds
and go down slowly
two
bounce bounce pass go up
on the toes hold it
and go down three
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
go down forward bounce balance bounce
go up
hold it
go down
five
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
hold up
six bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
keep your core tight
and um seven
bounce bounce pounds
go up
hold it
and go down eight bounce bounce bounce
go up on the toes
hold it keep your feet together
core tight
and down okay
relax
and we can go to the first exercise okay
in this first section
we will work on posture yeah we will do
three different exercises
and we will repeat this sequence of
three exercises four times okay
so for the first exercise you need the
wall
and what you do is this if you remember
my first video this would be familiar to
you but it's always good to repeat it
again
so you have to put your hip on the wall
like this you have to
put your feet a little bit away from the
from the wall yeah a bit of separation
and also a bit of separation between
both feet yeah more or less
shoulder width yeah like this and you
bend your knees a little bit yeah just
relax the legs we don't need them now
and the first thing you do is you put
your back flat against the wall
including the head
yeah
be careful don't make the back of your
neck small short
try to make it long
yeah so that your chest goes forward
and your head is straight yeah feel the
back of your neck long
and then what you do is this
you start from the head
and you take it away from the wall
and then from the head you continue
rolling down slowly
you take your back away from the wall
vertebrae
until the last thing touching the wall
is your hip yeah
be careful don't change the hip don't do
this keep your hip always straight yeah
like this make a curve
and then from here
you do the opposite you put your back on
the wall
again vertebral vibrator keeping your
head down
yeah now it's the chest
and then the last thing is the head
okay so basically you roll down starting
from the head
until your hip
and then
you roll up again
from the hip
until your head
okay
so let's do this eight times slowly
so start with the back
flat on the wall and then let's go
one
go down
and
go up
slowly
vertical elevator
this is one repetition
two
slow
roll down
and go up
two
three
start with the head
roll down
bring your background
and go up
slowly
three
four
go down slowly
and go up
vertically
four
five go down
slowly
roll down
and go up
under the head
six
go down
roll out of the wall
and then six go up
slowly perfect
[Music]
go up
and the last one eight
go down
slowly
don't change your hip
and go up
okay
and the last thing is the head
now from here comes the second exercise
and here the idea is to do the same but
instead of rolling from the head
you roll from the hip so the first
movement is
you contract your abdomen and you push
your hip forward like this
so it lifts the wall yeah
forward and then from here
you keep rolling your torso
until you reach
the more lesser chest yeah
and then from here you put your torso
again
on the wall
from the chest to the hip so basically
you take the hip away
then you take the rest of the back away
until your chest
and then you put your back again on the
wall starting from the chest and ending
on the hip yeah in the beginning is a
bit difficult this movement but it will
help you a lot for your center and your
posture okay
so let's do it eight times i keep my
arms up so that you can see what's going
on here yeah
so let's go
one
from the hip
up
and one from the chest down
until the hip
two
start with the hip
until the chest
shoulder blades
two
from the shoulder blades down to the hip
three
roll up
until the shoulder blades
and roll down
slowly vertically
under the hip
four
vertebrae
take it away from the wall
and then four
vertebrae
put it again on the wall
five
up
and down slowly
and
six
up
and down
seven
from the hip
up
and down
to the hip
slowly
eight from the hip
until the shoulder blades
up and then down from the shoulder
blades
vertical angle
under the hip
okay good then you stand away from the
wall and the third exercise you grab
your stick yeah
you want it away from the wall because
you need a bit of distance
and then you hold the stick in front of
you with a wide lip
the wider the grip the easier the
exercise is because what you have to do
is basically to raise the stick in front
of you
then above your head
and then if you can pass it
behind
until you can lower it
on your back like this yeah so a full
circle
if your grip is wide this will be easier
to do the narrower your grip is
the harder it becomes
to pass the sleep behind
yeah
this exercise is great to place your
shoulders in the right position for
example i have a tendency to put the
shoulders forward
so this exercise is great to
put the shoulders on the right position
so let's do it eight times yeah i will
start with a wide grip okay
so
one
and one
two
and two
three
and three
four
and four
five
and five keep your core tight here
six
and six
seven
and seven
eight
and eight yeah this is my routine for
poster so now we'll repeat the whole
thing again one more time okay let's
repeat the three poster exercises three
more times okay let's do it together so
keep on the wall
feet apart
and then put your back on the wall
and let's go eight times
start with the head
one roll down
until the hip and then up
one
two
slowly
down
[Music]
vertebral vibrator under your head
four
go down slowly
then go up
and five
roll down
until the hip
and
roll up under the head
six
[Music]
go up
and eight
go down slowly
onto the hip
and go
up
until here okay
now from the hip
to the chest okay so
roll up from the hip
until the shoulder blades
and then roll down slowly vertebrae
under your hip
two
roll up
and
roll down
slowly
bit by bit three
roll up
from the hip to the shoulder blades
and roll down from the shoulder blades
to the hip
four
roll up
and
roll down slowly
five
roll up
roll
down
until the heat six
roll up
and roll down
slowly
seven
heap
lower back
shoulder blades
and shoulder blades lower back hip
seven
roll up
roll down
[Music]
slowly
and eight
roll up
and roll
down
slowly yeah
okay then stand
grab the stick
and now i will grab the stick a little
bit narrow narrower than before
to make the exercise a little bit more
challenging
so hold it in front of you
and then pass it above your head until
you're back yeah
and then again
to the front that was one
two
back
and front
three
back
and forth slowly
four
bark
and front
five
back
and front
six
back
and front
seven
back in front
and eight keep your core tight all the
time back
and forth okay good
now let's go again
to the wall
put your hip
on the wall
then your back
and then let's do rolling from the head
eight times
one
down
and up
vertebrae
okay don't skip any part
two
head
shoulder blades
middle of the back
lower back until the hip yeah
and up
vertebrae
four
row down
and up
five
run down
roll up
six
go down
and roll up
and seven
roll down
[Music]
roll up
and the last one
eight
roll down
slowly
and roll up pressing every vertebra
against the wall
then we roll from the hip
and
one
and roll down
two start with the hip
then the lower back then undo the
shoulder plates
and roll down
three
roll up
and roll down
on
four
roll up
and roll down
slowly
five
roll up
and roll down
six
roll up
and roll down
seven
roll up
and then slowly
where the bra
roll down
seven
roll up
roll down slowly and
eight
roll up
and roll down
okay
then stand grab the stick
and let's do the shoulder exercise again
now if you can grab the stick even a bit
narrower yeah so it will be a little
more challenging
let's go
one
and one forward yeah this is challenging
two
and two
three
and three but by the third repetition it
gets easier yeah
four
now it's it feels easier than the first
repetition and four
five
and five this is no problem anymore
six
and
six four
seven
and seven
and eight
and eight okay
because by the time you do three or four
repetitions
the joint opens yeah starts to open it
gets used to it and then it feels easier
okay
now last time let's repeat the exercise
last time so
keep on the wall
back flat on the floor
back of the leg long yeah and then let's
roll down
one
slowly until the hip
and then go up
one two
down
[Music]
go up
three
down
and go up slowly
four
down
go up yeah put every vertebra
on the wall
five
down
slowly don't take shortcuts
go vertebrae by vertebra
and go up
six
go down
and go up
seven
roll down
slowly
and roll up
and eight
roll down
and go up
now we roll up from the hip up and down
okay
so one start from the hip then vertebrae
put your back away until the shoulder
makes
and then
down from the shoulder blades vertebrae
until the heel do it slowly
and don't take shortcuts don't do just
this yeah you have to roll
two
roll up
and roll
down slowly
three
roll up
and roll down making sure that you don't
skip any part of your back yeah
four
roll up
and roll
down
five
roll up
and roll
down slowly
six
roll up
and roll down
to the hip
seven
roll up
and roll down
eight
roll
up and roll down
okay
good
this exercise is great especially the
first part
because if you dance in close embrace
you are supposed to touch your partner
with the ribs
just below the chest not with the chest
but with the ribs that's what makes
contact and pressure on the doors of
your partner in closing breaks and this
exercise is really great for that to get
your rib cage forward
and to make contact with the ribs this
makes for a really good feeling in the
embrace okay now let's go for the
shoulders
also grab your stick and try to grab it
even a bit narrower yeah this will be
already hard for me to do
but let's try the first repetition will
be difficult yeah
one
[Music]
and one
two
and two
three
and three by a third is a bit easier
four
and four
five
and five
it feels easier right now
six
and six yeah the shoulder joint opens
seven
this feels fine
and
eight
and eight
okay
in the beginning it feels really hard
but then by the third four repetition
it really gets easier okay good so let's
go for the balance section okay now
start the segment on balance and you
will need the stick
and what i do is i repeat a sequence of
three different exercises over and over
and over
today we'll repeat them four times yeah
and
the third exercise will stay the same
the four times but the first two
exercises on the first two repetitions i
will show you an easier version and on
the last two repetitions i will show you
a slightly harder period so that you
have more options okay
so let's start with the first exercise
if you follow this channel from the
first technique videos that i uploaded
maybe this will seem familiar but i
didn't show it to you with a stitch this
is new today
so it goes like this you start with feet
together and you hold the stick in front
of you with a wide grip like this yeah
then you find your balance on one leg
whichever leg you want yeah and then you
raise the stick above your head making
sure that you lift it
using your rib cage yeah you lift your
ribcage and you also engage the muscles
of your upper back
so that your arms can relax yeah you're
holding the stitch basically with your
torso and not so much with the arms and
shoulders
okay then with your free leg you have
four positions the first position is
like this
you raise your knee in front of you yeah
until the thigh is more or less parallel
with the floor the second position is
you lower the leg and you touch the
floor behind you with the toes okay
the third position is you move your
weight
between both legs and you go down
until your free knee touches the floor
yeah the knee of the free leg
on the fourth position you push with
both legs
until you are up again and then you go
on the first position one
two
three
and four yeah
and you repeat this eight times okay
then we turn around and i will show you
from the other side we will do it eight
times to the other side okay this is the
first one let's do it together
so
legs together
find your balance on one leg
raise the stick rib cage up don't forget
your rib cage on your back during the
whole exercise okay
don't let
the arms go down and your torso do this
because you are concentrating on your
legs yeah keep some concentration for
the torso
and let's go eight times
one
two
three four
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and
eight two
three
and four okay lower the street relax and
let's go to the other side
so feet together
find your balance on the other leg raise
the stick ribcage up and back engaged
let's go eight times to this side
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four don't forget your torso
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
four okay relax
now let's go for the second exercise
which is quite similar
you start with feet together again
stick in front of you wide lip
and then you find again your balance on
your first leg
you raise the stick
and the first position for the free leg
is the same knee up but then from here
you move the leg behind you but you
don't touch the floor
you stretch the leg behind you like this
without touching the floor
then you bend the knee of the standing
leg
and then you go up
yeah so you have
one
two
three
and four and that's the exercise
so this leg is not touching the floor at
all yeah you are all the time on your
standing leg okay
so let's do it eight times
legs together feet together
find your balance
make sure your foot is completely flat
on the floor the toes are open
and raise the stick above your head rib
cage up don't forget it through the
exercise and let's do it eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three four
three
two
four
three
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
and four okay relax
relax standing leg especially yeah shake
it a bit
and then let's do the arms to the other
side feet together
find your balance and raise the stick
yeah
rib cage up back engage and let's do it
eight times with the other leg
one
two
three
four slow and controlled yeah
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four don't forget your torso
six
two
three
four core tight yeah
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
and four
okay relax
left legs and relax the shoulders as
well
and then we go to the third exercise
which works like this i will show you
from behind yeah
so this time you start with the legs
open like this yeah
more or less your
shoulder width yeah
and then the weight is on the center
both feet
and you raise the stick again then what
you do is you shift your weight to one
leg then you cross the free leg behind
the standing leg like this
and then you move your weight between
both legs and you go down
like this slowly until you touch the
floor with the knee
be careful don't bump the knee yeah
only a light touch and then go up
and then return to the center position
and then repeat to the other side
shift the weight to one leg cross the
other leg the free leg
behind the standing leg
place your weight on both legs
go slowly down control touch the knee on
the floor
and then go up and then return to the
center yeah
and each time you go to one side to both
sides is one repetition so we count
one
and one
two and two okay and we do it three
times okay so let's do it together you
can just follow me okay
so legs open
stick in front of you wait in the middle
make sure you are looking front and your
posture is straight
put the stick above your head make sure
your rib cage is up and your back is up
okay and then let's start
one
two
center
and
two
center
on
three
center
and
three go down control and go up control
center
four
go down
up
center
four
down
up
center
five down
up
center
five
down
up
center
six
down
up center
six
down
seven
up
center
seven
down
up
center
eight
down
up
seven
eight down
up
seven okay
so these are the
three exercises okay so now we will
repeat it one more time the same okay
before we repeat the three exercises
again i will show you what i do to
rest a bit in between repetitions
i stand with my feet a little bit apart
just like this not much
and then
very slowly i just bend over
making sure that my legs are completely
straight yeah the knees are stretched
and then i close my arms yeah i make
sure that
my neck is relaxed my back is relaxed
and the weight of the arms
pull my back down yeah make sure that
the legs are straight and then i just
wait in this position for 60 seconds i
just count 60 seconds
and then i go up slowly
and this will relax your lower back
because it tends to get tense during the
exercises okay
so
let's repeat again
the whole series of three exercises
so
feet together
stick in front of you
find your balance
stick above your head yeah make sure
your rib cage is up on the back engage
and also your core
and let's go for the first exercise and
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four don't forget your torso
six
two
three
four
[Music]
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four okay
now the same to the other side
so find your balance on the other leg
then raise the stick rib cage up back
engaged
and then let's go eight times
one
two
weight in the middle go down three
and four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
and four okay
good relax don't forget to
keep your standing foot all the time
flat on the floor with the toes relaxed
okay
now let's go for the second exercise the
one where
you just hold your leg behind without
touching the floor okay
so feet together
stick up
ribcage up
back engaged
and let's do it three times
one
two
three
four slow and controlled
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
four
okay good relax shoulders arms
legs and let's do it eight times to the
other side
feet together
stick up
ribcage up and back engage
core tight
find your balance make sure your
standing foot is completely flat and
relaxed
and then
let's go eight times one
two three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four keep your core tight
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two keep your core tight now
three when you go down
and four
okay good relax
and let's do the third exercise yeah
the one where you stand in the center
and then cross the leg go down
underneath and then center and to the
other side okay
let's do it eight times
legs open weight on the center heat
straight
raise the stick rib cage up back engaged
and let's go eight times to each side
ah
one
center
two
three
center
four
and
center
five
and
center
on
five
and center keep your core tight yeah
six
center
center rib cage up
seven
center
eight
okay
great that was the second repetition
so if you want
do the relaxing of your back
one minute
and then we go to the next repetition
okay on this repetition i will show you
slightly harder versions of the first
and the second exercise okay so let's
see how
this works for the first exercise
so the beginning is the same feet
together
find your balance on your standing leg
put the stick above your head
making sure that your rib cage is up on
your back engage now when you take the
first position with your free leg which
is the knee in front of you
at the same time you turn the torso
towards
the free leg like this yeah
only the torso not the head will leave
the head looking forward so only the
torso okay this is the first difference
then
when you
lower the free leg and move it behind
you you
return the torso to the center position
yeah you're looking forward
then the next difference is when you go
down now on both legs you don't go down
like this
on the
ball of the back foot
what you do is that you touch the floor
with the top of the toe with a nail okay
with an a and then
you slide the foot a little bit back
and you go down on top of the foot like
this okay
and then to go up you have to
push
with the front of the foot
and on the floor yeah like opening the
knee of the back foot
and then this will help you to go up and
then go again to the first position yeah
so this is the new version now
why do we use this well first of all
because it's a nice
stretch for the foot yeah it's really
really nice to stretch it
and also because this is really useful
if you ever do a tango show
and you have a choreography
with a pose at the end which goes down
yeah you do choreography variation
and at the end what you go down
this is the pose that you want for the
bad foot
because it looks better it follows the
line of the leg the foot follows the
lining of the leg
if you go down like this
yeah it works but it's a bit more
beginner yeah so what you want is to do
the last movement and then one like this
you have to smooth out like this
and
this exercise will
help you lose the fear
of going down on the front of the foot
and a technical tip for this is that
the part of the foot that presses down
on the floor when you are like this is
exactly the same one that you use when
you step
only on top yeah so when you do a ton of
step
every kind of teacher will tell you
that you have to make the pressure on
the floor with the
inside half of the foot yeah this one
and not this one yeah the inside so when
you use this movement
the part of the foot that presses
against the floor is also
the inside one
but on the top
yeah
so that's a new version okay let's do it
three times
slowly and controlled yeah
so feet together
find your balance on one leg
stick up don't forget your rib cage and
your butt during the whole exercise
and let's do it every time slowly
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
eight
two
three
four
okay
relax
you feel the foot is really stretched
yeah
that's what the
variation is for yeah to help you
stretch the foot okay
so let's do it eight times to this side
find your balance
raise the stick
ribcage up back engaged and let's go
eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
and four
okay
now the second exercise
well in this we will also use the
the torsion
so we start in the same way fit together
find your balance
then raise the stick
and then on the first position also we
use the torso yeah the torsion towards
the free leg
when you when you lower the leg and move
it back
then you return the torso to the front
position yeah remember in this version
of the exercise you don't touch the
floor with the back foot
then you go low
with a leg
standing leg this is the same
and then up this is the same yeah so in
this exercise we only introduce the
torsion on the first position okay
that's it
so let's do it eight times feet together
find your balance
on your first leg
put the stick above your head
ribcage up
and back engaged
and then let's go eight times
one
with torsion
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four don't forget the torso
five
two
three
four
six
two
three 4
and
two
three
four okay
one tip is
when you are doing the torsion make sure
that you don't bend the elbow behind you
yeah sometimes
we do this no no
keep the elbows both elbows straight and
make the torsion below above your hip
yeah on the torso only
yeah like this
the arms don't do anything okay
so let's do it eight hands to the other
side
same thing
feet together find your balance on the
other leg
stick above your head
rip cage up
and let's go eight times
slow and control
one both elbows straight yeah
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
four
okay
relax
and then we do the last one yeah the
third exercise
so remember you start in the middle
center
the weight on the center and then you
shift your weight to one leg you cross
the free leg behind you go down on both
legs until you touch the knee behind on
the floor you go up
return to the center and do the same to
the other side and this is one position
okay
let's do it eight times so feet open
just a little bit shoulder width
stick up
ribcage up back engage
and let's go
and
cross the leg
pull down
one
up
and center
cross the leg
go down
one
up
and center
and
two
[Music]
keep your core tight here
and four
and center
and
five
and center don't forget your back yeah
and center
and
six
and center
and
six
and center relax the arms ribcage up ah
seven
and center
and
seven
and center
and
eight
and center
okay
great
so if you want now you can relax again
with the exercise i showed you before
one minute just bend down relax
and then we go for the last repetition
of this okay so let's do the last
repetition of these three exercises and
let's use again the harder version okay
so we start with the first
remember
uh when you lift your knee torsion
when you put the foot behind and go down
you go on the top of the foot okay so
let's go feet together find your balance
and then raise the stick above your head
ribcage out back engaged and let's go
anytime
one
two
three
four slow and controlled yeah
two
three
four
two
three
four
two
three
four don't forget your thoughts five
two
three keep your core tight
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and
eight
two
round slowly
three
go up slowly
and four
okay good relax
relax the standing leg and let's do it
eight times to the other side
so feet together find your balance on
the other leg
raise the stick and let's go eight times
one torsion towards the free leg
two
toe on the floor touch the floor with
the nail
three rest your weight on the top of the
foot
push with the top of the foot four
two
three
four
two
three keep your core tight
four
two
three
go up slowly
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
four
and eight
two
three
and
four
okay good relax
and then let's do the second exercise
yeah
remember
that the first position is the same with
the torsion but then
you extend the freely back and you don't
touch the floor you just go down with
the standing knee and then up again
okay we do it eight times
kick together
praise the stick
breathe deeply make sure your core is
tight with cage up and back engaged
and let's go
one
two
three
four
slow and controlled
two
three
four keep your core tight yeah three
two three three
four
two
three
four
five
two
three
four
six
two
three
core tight
four
seven
two
three
four
oops eight
sorry
two
three
four
okay
let's go to the other side
so find your buttons
and raise the stick
rib cage up and don't forget the torso
during the whole exercise let's go let's
go eight times
one
two
three
four
two
three
four yeah move slowly
two three
four
two
three
four
five
two
don't forget you're standing there yeah
three
[Music]
four
six
two
three
four
seven
two
three
slow
four
and eight
core tight
two
three
and
four
okay good
relax
relax shoulders and legs
and now let's do the third exercise yeah
and here let's also use
the technique
with the front of the foot yeah so when
you cross the leg behind you and then
you go back
touch the floor with the nail of the toe
then slide the foot a little bit back
and then go down
resting on the top of the foot then
push with the top of the foot down on
the floor to go up and return to the
center yeah
we introduce this change in this
exercise as well okay
let's do it eight times
feet open shoulder width
weight in the center
stick up
ribcage up and back engage
then
wait on one leg
close the free leg behind
touch the floor with a
nail
slide then down on both legs
one
go up
and center
and cross
one
and
center
two
three
five lock control
center
five
and
center
six
uh
center
six
and
center
ah
seven
core tight
center
comforted your torso and
seven
and center
the last one
eight
watts slowly
[Music]
center
and
eight
cylinder
okay and uh we are done that was it
so if this was too hard
you can
use
a chair just take a chair
and grab the back of the chair yeah and
then just do all the exercises
grabbing the chair yeah this one also
yeah you can have the chair on the side
so you can move the leg freely yeah
uh you can also use the wall yeah you
can use the wall support yourself
yeah this will be
the next step
once you feel comfortable with the chair
of the wall and it's easy then you can
do the exercises holding your hips with
your hands yeah you can do everything
all the exercises holding your hips yeah
and then when this is easy you can
progress to the stick
if you find it too difficult then you
can hold the stick in front of you
but i really recommend that you try
with a stick above your head yeah
because then the stick is aligned with
your axis yeah and also you can use the
if you hold the stick in front of you
your shoulders are still working a bit
too much yeah but if you hold it
uh on top of your head then
your
muscle uh your muscles in the torso are
holding the stick yeah
your back
your side yeah your rib cage
and then you can really relax your your
arms yeah so these are ways in which you
can progress to this level if you find
this too challenging and let me know in
the comments if you are trying these
exercises if you are giving them a
chance that means
exercise them over a period of time yeah
and then let me know if you really feel
a difference if they are really helping
you okay i'm really interested to hear
from you
okay so thank you very much for watching
thank you a lot for the people who are
supporting the channel with little
donations they really help
and
i will see you very soon in the next
video bye